you know Tate's been getting canceled
for this nonsense lately and this video
came out about him showing some creepy
Behavior this might be a little bit
weird to watch with my mom but I figured
it's good content to react to oh boy I
haven't even seen it yet so you know
what maybe he is being creepy we'll see
you don't have none of these issues do
you baby
change oh babies
that's not what you do at night at night
you know what she does she attacks me
koala bears me
I can't even move I can't even breathe
yesterday oh okay
is that the club so in this video we're
going to be looking at this really
creepy was that the clip is this what
they're coming after him for has he have
these people like never left their house
I'm sorry am I missing something have
these people like they're in a
relationship like there's like that
happens I have been treated worse than
that by complete strangers and not
complained and not trying to have their
lives ruined I cannot take this standard
by which all these people pretend that
we're supposed to act like is if
everybody's so wonderful and there's
just a couple of outliers who act like
this give me a break is this is that the
whole thing no there's if that was it
language
Tristan this video hasn't really been
that public so I thought I'd try and
bring it to light to show you just how
oh my God I don't believe that you don't
like totally could you even believe oh
my God if somebody ever treated you like
that I would totally [__] take my
wine glass and smash it over their face
like no it's not happening why are you
talking like because that's what young
college girls are doing when they watch
this and using this to actually hate and
despise someone she's not in the mood
for his [__] he did something annoying
they're in a relationship and she's just
like leave me alone like that's that
that this is like normal this guy has
200k hold up please tell me there's more
to the video this is behave exactly the
way he wants you to so let's take a look
you just came up being with girls most
of the time you're right but this time
you're wrong this girl he did not see
this girl most of the time you're right
because everyone wants to be with a take
it's normal every girl wants to be with
the King
yeah everyone oh not everyone she's
acting bad while she's here in my hotel
room having sex exactly just like so act
tough
last night it was all
maripula
what is that might pull up peanut
so I'm going to ignore the extreme
egotism here and just focus on the raw
body language this girl who supposedly
takes then girlfriend gotta remember
they're sitting at a table and they're
filming a video like every time there's
a camera out there's some sense of
character being played too right and we
can't see their faces so her body
language is actually it now okay this is
going to your body language analyst an
expert my non-expert opinion tells me
this girl looks pretty freaking chill
she's got a pack of smokes a nice drink
she's leaned back in her chair she's got
her legs so oppressed if you feel like
you have to like get away from people
you're really upset you're not sitting
with leaned back with your leg up and
your phone in your hand like yeah you
know I mean come on I mean am I wrong no
I know she's so this girl she's fine
fine he's so oppressed with her avaral
spirits I don't like this Converse
I don't think that what happens in the
bedroom between the two of them should
be fodder for conversation or even
filmed or filmed but they're drinking
who knows you know how many drinks
they've had at this point another thing
is he has like thousands of hours of
footage so if we're gonna go through
everything and take 30 second Clips yeah
he's gonna look a bit like a dick I'm
sure if every if you went through every
single one of our videos to make up two
minute documentary if I were evil it
could be done oh it's there have people
done that I don't think anyone's done
that you should just do it and we should
just do it make a new account and just
no just release released
this is a pacifying behavior and is the
brain's way of regulating stress by
distracting itself with physical touch
clearly she's uncomfortable listening to
the absolute nonsense being spoken Tate
kind of picks up on this and you see him
playing with the bottle cap he realizes
that she's uncomfortable so he tries to
make physical contact with her using the
bottle cap to build what's called
rapport with her basically it's I think
the girl on the right here does look a
little more she looks a little more
annoyed she's like
she's mad at him for some reason
something about yep keep going this has
gotten on her nerves let's see what this
guy looks like don't even tell me that's
what this guy looks like that's making
the video come on you can like oh he's
he's in the Army too I respect for that
yes that's dope but I mean bro bro
what is kitty cat headphones
okay qualified body language analyst I
mean if I had qualified if you had to
put my like if you gave me three
pictures of guys like normal looking
dudes and then this one and said who
made this video I would bet my life it
was this guy literally put my life on it
say to her that she's not behaving
properly and this physical touch is a
way of him signaling to her that he's
clocking on to this she then hilariously
brushes it off with a hand showing that
she's refusing to listen to his cue
she's obviously annoyed with him and
uncomfortable being around him so no
this girl he didn't do no he's innocent
I said how many times do we meet only
two she goes I think yes haha but we
didn't sleep I know what happened he's
apologized but she's that mad that she's
wrong isn't that crazy
Mike told me your mom
yeah Mike Mike told me he [__] your
mom 20 years ago so he might be your dad
I don't care what people say yeah I
can't stand this kind of talk I can't I
I can't stand when men talk like this in
front of women I'm okay with locker room
talk in the locker room this is just
crass to me and I'm okay with us
watching it together because I actually
it's it for me it's a point for me to
remind you not to be sitting around at
drinks talking like this with a woman oh
yeah if I after and I did it this way in
that way and this way yeah I'd tell you
I mean why would you ever talk even if
this woman who this woman clearly
doesn't mean anything to him or he
wouldn't be talking to her you know to
her like that they talk a lot about
being respectful I mean he's treating
her dude like she's cheap and she's
taking it so she can't be that
uncomfortable because she does have the
ability she has at least one leg that I
can see to get up and walk away from
this table yeah I mean that's the thing
like yeah we can be reasonable people
and be like yeah he shouldn't have said
that but it's also not like he's the
worst human ever like we're all people
like I said there's a thousand there's
thousands of hours of footage you're
gonna go through find it where he's
being a little bit shitty talking across
the girls like yeah you shouldn't do
that but it's not like like I've also
seen tons of footage where he's like
amazing to people so it's like yeah give
me a break don't care that's why no this
is a lesson after that this is this is
the lesson about women let me tell you
if this girl said yes Tristan you [__]
me she would be happy that she's right I
didn't like her and she's angry because
she's wrong she's angry I did not okay
next time every time she says
well I'll tell you if someone's going to
be a jealous lunatic you might as well
just go out and do whatever you want
because if you're gonna have to get in a
fight and scream and yell in a
relationship you might as well at least
be uh you know earning earning it if
you're gonna fight either way I I had
like one jealous boyfriend once who was
just such I never did anything I never
did anything wrong and he was such a
pain in the ass and he just was always
accusing me of this or that or this or
that and like one time um we're in my
house it was like two o'clock in the
morning and the phone rang and I didn't
get to it fast enough and the answering
machine came on and um whoever it was
didn't leave a message this was even
before caller ID existed we had an
actual answering machine with a tape and
my God he started a fight with me over
that I had no idea who it was there was
nobody trying to booty call me it could
have been any one of my friends it could
have been any wrong number anything and
you couldn't call back the number no no
we didn't have the call so but I I we
got into a fight for like an hour and
I'm like I look back now I'm like why
was I so good to him I should should
have cheated on him if I had to stand
there and get yelled at all the time
anyway I might as well have earn you
know earned her on some fun yeah Haram
sorry
it's ridiculous then you're always right
baby then you're always right yeah
you're mad that I didn't because you're
wrong and I'm right is that how women
are that is kind of funny though that
they like almost would have rather he
done it to be right because that's how
but that's how jealous people are if
that guy would have just preferred it so
he could be right he'd be like I told
you I caught you I don't know it's I
think it's different with guys and girls
I don't know I don't know if you've ever
met a jealous guy like it's really
painful to deal with really getting
stressed here that his then yeah but the
thing is like if the guy actually caught
you I mean I don't know it probably
would have just ended the relationship
but with this since it's like the guy
being monogamous isn't as important she
would have rather be right in this
situation and have him sleep with
someone else yeah you see what I'm
saying he doesn't care that he sleeps
around so I don't even know why it's a
conversation I don't even know how this
came out you're taking the tape brother
she got baited into it and you're
complaining about them sleeping around I
mean it's like going to McDonald's and
complaining you get the [__] it's like
come on
closing off to him which is why you see
him using the bottle cap to pacify he
whacks it on the table numerous amounts
of times which is considered fidgeting
he's getting stressed that she's closing
off to him showing that he's either
upset which to be honest I doubt or his
ego is being hurt because she's not
giving him I've seen him fidget like
that countless times even on the I could
even like put in my head on the milk
boys podcast I remember him going like
this with his hand was he nervous he
does I've seen him fidget with like um
I don't know lighter or he's just yeah
he's just a he's got a lot of energy
he's a fidgeter so a little bit it's
[__] guy thinks he knows everything
guy what the [__] I'm not saying that
there isn't something oh they're 100 of
course there is but you when you can't
see the girl's faces it seems a little
ridiculous to be this confident in your
analysis incredibly hedonistic
conversation and puts her coat on to
leave she's obviously very uncomfortable
here people I'm glad our relationship
does not happen
me and you we're different we don't have
none of these issues do you baby
I'll except for the pool
I don't want to be near you oh babies
that's not what you do at night at night
you know what she does she attacks me
koala bears me
I can't even move I can't even breathe
yesterday
if this was Harvey Weinstein or Kevin
Spacey everyone will be crying about how
much of a creep he is but for some
reason people look past this this is
incredibly creepy and twisted Behavior
he's literally grabbing her this guy
what what bubble does this guy live in
that this is quote unquote incredibly
creepy and twisted Behavior it's his
girlfriend bro you give me a break he
refuses to put up with Tate and his
brother Tate demonstrates in this very
short space of Time how fragile his ego
is that he gets super stressed when he
can't control every woman around him let
alone his girl super pathetic and creepy
last-ditch attempt at controlling this
woman says all you need to know about
this guy he doesn't respect women yeah
he's not a gentleman you're right buddy
he says everything you're everything
anybody would ever needs to know he's
right of course case dismissed case
dismissed send him the [__] Abdul get
the Rocks send him to prison he he he
held on to his his girlfriend he pulled
the chair closer because he's being
annoying this is all this behavior is
it's just annoying like I'd be like just
get off me leave me alone [__] off
you're bugging me for a minute piss off
for a minute I'm annoyed with you
exactly the people who idolize him
everyone would have cut down this girl
over here is someone on the left is
feeling extremely stressed chivalry
beats here she's extremely stressed like
she's sipping on her drink now it looks
terrible yeah she's it just looks awful
and I'm sure she's she's not gonna have
to pick up the checks poor chick so
thank you so much for watching this
video guys if you did enjoy it please be
sure to hit the like button and
subscribe for more content and I'll see
you it's not how often I do this it's
not often I do this also what colors
what color is your jail cell oh excuse
me I I don't dislike videos but I'm
disliking this one all right thank you
guys so much for watching make sure to
like subscribe and have and have a
thicker skin than that guy I mean I if
you see a woman in distress yes help her
out but those women were not in distress
they could have gotten up and walked
away from that table at any moment and
they they were not being threatened me a
break
[Music]